Quando pubblico un episodio di Pensieri in codice,
cerco sempre di dedicare il massimo impegno per
ottenere la migliore qualità audio possibile.
Questo perché ritengo che un prodotto che arriva nelle tue cuffie,
e quindi nelle tue orecchie,
debba essere molto curato dal punto di vista sonoro,
ovviamente.
Ma una cosa del genere,
per un piccolo podcast come il mio,
è relativamente semplice.
Hai mai pensato invece a quanto sia complicato
veicolare il suono in contesti più complessi,
come ad esempio un concerto o uno spettacolo?
Beh,
nell'episodio della serie Community Edition di oggi,
Alex Ordiner,
responsabile tecnico audiovisivo,
ci illustrerà,
con esempio e dovizia di particolari,
proprio le varie fasi della gestione dell'audio durante un evento dal vivo.
Dopo la sigla,
quindi,
scopriremo come funziona il suono,
come viene gestita la catena audio,
quali sono gli strumenti tecnici e perché
vengono utilizzati in determinati modi,
e,
più in generale,
quanto può essere complessa l'organizzazione di
un qualcosa che magari noi diamo per scontato.
Buon ascolto!
Benvenuti su Pensieri in Codice,
il podcast dove si ragiona da informatici,
con Valerio Galano.
Ciao a tutti,
ed eccoci qua in questo piccolo esperimento in cui provo
a raccontarvi il dietro le quinte di uno spettacolo,
di un evento dal vivo,
di una situazione live,
insomma.
Più che altro per capire la parte tecnica di tutta questa questione,
cioè che cosa succede a grandi linee,
che apparecchiature sono utilizzate,
ma anche che professionalità sono coinvolte e qual è il loro ruolo.
Gli aspetti da affrontare sono tanti,
e ovviamente non sono competente su tutti.
Però,
anche decidendo di trattare solo i principali,
ho valutato che affrontare inizialmente un solo aspetto
potrebbe rendere le cose più semplici e comprensibili.
Iniziarei quindi dall'audio.
Ho pensato di impostarla così e vorrei raccontare quali sono
i macroelementi di una catena audio inizialmente e per poi
andarli a scovare e a rintracciare in varie situazioni,
da quelle più piccole fino a eventi medi
per arrivare fino agli eventi molto grandi.
Prima di vedere proprio praticamente tutte le apparecchiature coinvolte,
permettetemi di fare una carrellata veloce,
non preoccupatevi,
sulla struttura della catena audio,
quello che avviene in un evento dal vivo moderno,
e trovare e identificare le sue principali componenti.
Iniziamo quindi questa carrellata con una semplice immagine in mente.
C'è una persona che sta parlando,
un oratore che sta parlando,
noi siamo gli spettatori di fronte a lui e sentiamo la sua voce.
Allora,
cosa sta succedendo praticamente?
Iniziamo dal nostro oratore.
Lui sta parlando,
sta emettendo un suono.
E qua già ci fermiamo subito.
Che cos'è un suono?
Non andremo troppo nel tecnico,
chi conosce l'argomento mi perdoni le semplificazioni,
ma il suono è una variazione di pressione che si propaga in un mezzo.
Nel nostro caso il mezzo è l'aria,
cioè questo gas che ci circonda,
l'atmosfera.
E un corpo elastico che si muove in questo mezzo,
cioè un corpo capace di vibrare,
produce un cambiamento di pressione.
Pensate a una corda di una chitarra,
tesa fra due punti.
Quando la pizzico,
la colpisco,
la faccio vibrare,
questa oscilla.
Oscillando si sposta nello spazio,
ed è come se in un momento spingesse l'aria in un verso,
poi la corda oscilla dall'altra parte ed è come se richiamasse l'aria,
poi la rispinge,
la richiama e avanti così,
creando dei momenti di pressione seguiti
subito dopo da dei momenti di depressione.
Ecco,
ed è proprio questa la variazione di pressione che ci interessa.
Questa cosa la potremmo fare anche semplicemente spostando una mano nell'aria,
potrebbe venire da pensare.
Cioè spingo la mano lontano da me,
poi la ritiro verso di me,
la rispingo e via avanti.
Sto creando effettivamente delle zone di pressione e delle zone di depressione.
Però questo movimento è troppo lento perché il nostro corpo possa sentirla.
La nostra fisiologia,
infatti,
è tarata per sentire delle vibrazioni che vanno molto
approssimativamente dalle 20 volte fino alle 20.000 volte al secondo.
Proprio la nostra storia evolutiva ha privilegiato il
fatto che fossimo sensibili a questo range di frequenze.
Non sentiamo né le frequenze più basse né le frequenze più alte,
quelle che vengono chiamate suoni subsonici o ultrasuoni.
Abbiamo detto,
quindi,
che questa variazione di pressione si propaga nel mezzo,
nell'atmosfera.
Infatti,
come recita un famoso sottotitolo di un film,
"nello spazio nessuno può sentirti urlare"
perché manca il mezzo di trasmissione appunto.
Questa onda di pressione che si propaga,
mano a mano che si allontana dalla sorgente,
cioè nel nostro caso l'oratore che parla,
si affievolisce col passare dello spazio.
Mano a mano che appunto si allontana dall'emettitore
il suono cara di intensità fino a diventare inudibile.
Se quest'onda sonora,
prima di essersi affievolita del tutto incontra un ascoltatore,
quest'ultimo tramite i suoi organi di senso,
principalmente le orecchie,
non solo ma diciamo le orecchie,
la percepisce.
La nostra struttura biologica quindi fa sì che siamo sensibili a questo range
di variazione di frequenze e mandiamo questi dati al nostro cervello che
li traduce e ci fa vivere l'esperienza del suono per come la conosciamo.
ritorniamo alla nostra immagine iniziale.
Se l'ascoltatore è troppo lontano,
oppure c'è troppa confusione o l'oratore ha una voce troppo bassa,
l'ascoltatore non riuscirà a sentire o comunque a comprendere le parole.
Ecco quindi il problema che tecnologicamente tenteremo di risolvere,
ovvero quello di farci sentire.
Storicamente non abbiamo certo incominciato in
tempi recenti ad affrontare questo problema.
Tecniche ed accorgimenti per farsi sentire in varie situazioni.
Immagino siano stati inventate dall'alba dei tempi.
È un problema che ci siamo sempre posti.
Abbiamo infatti sviluppato tecniche oratorie per aumentare proprio la voce.
Abbiamo sviluppato luoghi che sfruttano le caratteristiche,
la diffusione del suono a nostro vantaggio.
Abbiamo di fatto inventato i teatri,
gli anfiteatri,
gli auditorium.
Abbiamo creato il palco dove chi parla è rialzato rispetto agli ascoltatori.
Insomma,
tecniche ce ne sono state tante,
sono interessantissime,
però a noi in questo podcast interessa la parte tecnologica della cosa.
Quindi partiamo da quando arriva l'elettronica in questo mondo a darci una mano.
Che cosa ci siamo inventati quindi?
Immaginiamo di mettere una sorta di orecchio elettronico vicino al
nostro oratore e questo orecchio elettronico capta l'onda sonora,
cioè la variazione del campo di pressione,
e la traduce in un segnale elettrico.
La traduce nella maniera più fedele possibile o comunque con delle
caratteristiche che abbiamo reputate valide per il nostro scopo.
Non è un segnale elettrico casuale,
è un segnale che si muove in qualche modo copiando il segnale sonoro,
cioè la mia grandezza fisica.
Il suono infatti viene catturato e tradotto in un segnale elettrico,
infatti si parla di trasduttore,
una specie di interprete fra queste grandezze.
Questo segnale elettrico,
dicevamo,
si muove copiando e mimando il segnale sonoro.
Se c'è un aumento di pressione nel segnale sonoro
avrò un aumento del valore del segnale elettrico.
Quando avrò invece una depressione nel segnale sonoro
avrò magari un valore negativo nel segnale elettrico.
Ecco che appunto questo segnale varia in maniera
analoga alla variazione del nostro segnale,
la nostra grandezza fisica del segnale sonoro.
Infatti parliamo proprio di segnale analogico,
cioè che si muove per analogia.
A questo punto ho un segnale elettrico che,
tra virgolette,
copia il mio segnale fisico,
il mio suono.
Che vantaggi posso trarne?
Beh,
noi abbiamo imparato a fare tante cose con un segnale elettrico.
Una di queste ad esempio è quella di trasportarlo.
Con dei conduttori possiamo trasportarlo da un punto ad un altro a una velocità
che per il nostro scopo possiamo tranquillamente approssimare all'istantaneità.
Posso però fare un'altra cosa.
Posso utilizzare un orecchio elettronico al contrario.
Cioè,
mentre prima captavo un'onda sonora e la traducevo in un segnale elettrico,
adesso metto un altro dispositivo,
un altro trasduttore,
che lavora al contrario,
cioè che riceve in ingresso un segnale
elettrico e mette in movimento una membrana,
cioè un qualcosa che fisicamente vibra nell'aria,
producendo un suono.
E questo movimento meccanico sarà stato fatto in analogia al segnale elettrico,
che a sua volta era in analogia al segnale sonoro.
Quindi,
in pratica,
io ho catturato un suono da una parte,
l'ho fatto correre,
l'ho trasportato nei conduttori e l'ho riemesso
in ambiente in un altro punto dello spazio.
Avrete capito,
immagino,
che il primo orecchio elettronico,
quello che capta il suono,
è quello che chiamiamo normalmente microfono.
Mentre il secondo orecchio elettronico,
quello al contrario,
quello che emette il suono,
è quello che chiamiamo speaker,
cassa,
altoparlante.
Eccoci quindi,
iniziamo a entrare nel concreto.
Quindi,
prendo un microfono,
tiro un cavo,
lo collego ad un altoparlante e...
avrò un suono?
Teoricamente sì,
ma in pratica non funziona così.
Non funziona perché il segnale elettrico che
produce il microfono è veramente piccolo,
è troppo poco potente per poter mettere meccanicamente
in movimento la membrana dell'altoparlante.
Qua apro una piccola parentesi.
Cercherò di non usare mai i termini come tensione,
corrente,
potenza,
resistenza,
dal punto di vista tecnico.
Utilizziamo un generico "forza" o "energia",
non dal punto di vista fisico,
ma proprio da un punto di vista colloquiale.
Non ci serve,
secondo me,
in questo ambito,
utilizzare i termini tecnici precisi,
non stiamo facendo calcoli.
Ci serve,
invece,
capirne i concetti generali.
Quindi,
ritorniamo al nostro microfono.
Genera una corrente piccolissima,
molto poco potente,
molto debole,
che non è in grado di muovere l'altoparlante.
E quindi?
Abbiamo già perso?
È già finito tutto?
No,
perché noi abbiamo imparato a farci tante cose con il segnale elettrico.
Sappiamo infatti creare dispositivi che accettano in ingresso questo segnale
molto molto debole e in uscita ci danno lo stesso segnale ma più potente.
E come fanno a funzionare?
Perché in ingresso,
dentro al nostro segnale debole,
ricevono anche una scorta di potenza,
sempre elettrica,
che possono utilizzare.
E' la classica alimentazione di corrente.
Questi dispositivi quindi prendono questa energia e
la utilizzano per rafforzare il mio segnale debole,
ingrandendolo,
rendendolo più forte,
ma cercando di mantenere il più possibile intatta la sua informazione.
Il segnale è sempre quello,
è semplicemente molto più potente.
Se metto quindi questo dispositivo fra il mio microfono e il mio altoparlante,
prendo il mio segnale molto molto debole,
lo amplifico,
lo rendo molto più forte,
lo mando all'altoparlante,
allora sì che lui si muoverà e creerà un
suono derivato dal mio segnale elettrico.
Questo apparecchio che abbiamo introdotto è l'amplificatore.
Riceve un segnale audio debole e,
sfruttando un'alimentazione,
fornisce un'uscita,
un segnale audio amplificato adatto a muovere meccanicamente l'altoparlante.
Questa cosa mi dà subito un altro grosso vantaggio,
oltre che catturare un suono da una parte in un punto e riemetterlo in un altro,
mi dà ad esempio la possibilità di riemetterlo in
un ambiente molto più forte di quello originale.
Ma se gli oratori sono più di uno,
mi serve quindi un amplificatore o uno speaker per ogni microfono?
Sì,
funzionerebbe,
certamente funzionerebbe,
ma è poco conveniente,
sia da un punto di vista logistico che economico.
Però torniamo allo stesso punto,
noi sappiamo trattare i segnali elettrici e
un'altra cosa che sappiamo fare è saperli unire.
Posso mettere quindi più microfoni,
farli convergere tutti in un unico dispositivo che me li miscela,
me li unisce,
e mi dà in uscita un unico segnale che poi
verrà amplificato e andrà agli speaker.
Questo oggetto è il mixer,
perché "miscelatori" in italiano suonava male.
Questo mixer poi nella pratica,
oltre a semplicemente unirmi vari segnali microfonici,
fa tantissime altre cose.
Ad esempio mi livella tutti i segnali dei microfoni,
perché potrei avere dei microfoni che mi
forniscono un segnale elettrico molto basso,
qualcuno leggermente più forte,
comunque basso,
ma leggermente un po' più forte,
o potrei avere l'audio di un lettore musicale,
di un computer,
che è più forte di un segnale microfonico.
Il mixer quindi prende tutti questi segnali,
me li livella con un primo stadio,
me li porta in una zona di lavoro.
Questo primo stadio viene detto di preamplificazione,
cioè me li pareggia in potenza,
diciamo,
me li rende tutti omogenei.
Oltre a questo,
questo dispositivo può anche processare il segnale,
può cambiarne l'equalizzazione,
la dinamica,
aggiungere effetti creativi.
Magari di questo faremo qualche piccolo accenno più avanti.
Quindi abbiamo detto che unisce questi segnali e crea un'uscita,
ma in verità crea più uscite,
molte uscite differenti a seconda del nostro scopo.
Questo è un aspetto secondo me interessante e poco conosciuto,
su cui vorrei spendere due parole più avanti.
Ma con questo,
secondo me,
abbiamo chiuso quelli che sono i macroelementi principali
che troviamo in una catena audio di un evento dal vivo.
Nel prossimo blocco andremo a cercare questi
elementi all'interno di situazioni reali,
dalle più piccole alle più grandi.
Eccoci quindi pronti a trovare i nostri macroelementi in situazioni reali.
Iniziamo da un esempio molto piccolo.
Il venditore a una festa di paese,
a una sagra.
Sta parlando,
usando un piccolo sistema di amplificazione,
a una piccola folla radunata davanti a lui.
Allora,
iniziamo ad analizzare i componenti.
Il nostro uomo avrà un microfono ad archetto,
quello che viene collegato all'orecchio o alla testa,
che porta la capsula del microfono molto molto vicino alla bocca,
attraverso uno stelo che corre sulla guancia.
Mi fermo subito su questo esempio,
per aprire subito una parentesi,
e parlare della posizione del microfono
rispetto alla sorgente che vogliamo catturare.
In questo caso,
la bocca del venditore.
In tutti i casi in cui andiamo a posizionare un microfono,
la posizione di questo microfono in relazione
alla sorgente sonora e all'ambiente,
è uno degli aspetti più importanti quando bisogna gestire un'amplificazione,
ma anche altre cose,
come ad esempio una registrazione.
Non è assolutamente un aspetto secondario,
anzi.
Questo perché,
oltre al tipo di suono,
al colore del suono che il microfono dà,
a seconda di dove viene messo,
volevo soffermarmi sul fatto che il microfono non sa cosa deve catturare,
cioè non sa cosa interessa a noi,
non sa quello che per noi è segnale e quello che invece è rumore.
Mi spiego.
Nel nostro esempio,
il venditore che parla è quello che definiamo segnale,
ma lo definiamo noi segnale.
In quell'ambiente,
la sua voce sarà mischiata con il rumore della folla,
la confusione,
la musica che è intorno.
Il microfono,
questa differenza fra ciò che è segnale e ciò che è rumore,
non può capirla.
Lui è semplicemente un trasduttore immerso nell'onda sonora che lo travolge,
che è composto da tutte queste cose,
da quello che per noi è segnale e da quello che per noi è rumore.
Quindi il nostro scopo,
lo scopo del tecnico,
è quello di posizionare il microfono in maniera da
massimizzare il segnale e ridurre il rumore già naturalmente,
già solo per come è posizionato il microfono.
E quindi direte voi,
è molto semplice,
basta sempre mettere il microfono il più vicino possibile alla sorgente.
E in moltissimi casi è proprio così.
Non è sempre detto però,
perché magari pensate di registrare un pianoforte
in una bella sala con una bella acustica,
per noi parte del segnale è anche il suono della stanza,
è anche come suona la stanza.
In quel caso il riverbero farà parte del mio
segnale perché gli darò una connotazione positiva,
mentre molto probabilmente in una conferenza
il riverbero avrà solo connotazioni negative.
Io cercherò di posizionare il microfono il più vicino
possibile all'oratore per cercarlo di isolare il più
possibile dall'ambiente per garantirne la comprensibilità.
Quindi,
stabilito che la scelta di dove posizionare il microfono
è determinante per la riuscita del nostro intento,
ritorniamo al nostro esempio.
Quindi il venditore col suo microfono ad archetto.
Questo microfono è collegato a una cassa che vediamo come una scatola nera,
cioè proprio un unico oggetto nero,
da cui sentiamo uscire il suono amplificato.
E quindi tutti gli elementi che abbiamo visto prima non ci sono?
No,
no,
ci sono proprio tutti,
semplicemente che sono racchiusi in un unico oggetto.
Quindi il segnale elettrico del nostro microfono viaggia via cavo,
o via radio o wireless,
ma non entriamo in questa differenza,
entra in questo parallelepipede e il primo
stadio che incontrerà sarà un preamplificatore,
sicuramente.
Potrebbe anche essere accompagnato da un piccolo mixer,
pensiamo ad esempio a una cassa,
che mi dà la possibilità di collegare via bluetooth un telefono.
Ecco,
questa è una componente mixer molto semplice,
ma quello è,
è esattamente il mixer.
L'uscita di questo stadio mixer viene mandata a un amplificatore.
L'amplificatore è sempre interno,
non lo vediamo da fuori come elemento separato.
A sua volta questo amplificatore va all'altoparlante,
sempre internamente.
Noi tutti questi cavi e collegamenti non li vediamo,
ma vediamo un unico grande oggetto nero.
Potremmo addirittura non vedere nemmeno la presa
dall'alimentazione collegata a questo apparato.
Ma ciò non vuol dire che sta lavorando senza potenza,
senza corrente.
La fonte di alimentazione c'è e in questo caso è una batteria.
Sarà una cassa a batteria che ogni tanto dovrà
essere rimessa in carica per funzionare.
Passiamo ora a un altro esempio,
un po' più interessante.
Quello di una piccola conferenza.
Arriviamo come spettatori,
vediamo un palco,
vediamo un podio.
Sul palco ci sono svariati microfoni,
non c'è nessuno in questo momento che sta parlando,
mentre al podio c'è una persona che sta parlando.
Vediamo due casse ai lati di questo piccolo
palchetto e sentiamo la voce amplificata.
Prima di andare a cercare tutti gli elementi,
ce la immaginiamo alla stessa situazione magari in un teatro,
in un piccolo teatrino,
in un auditorium.
Ipotizziamo di avere più difficoltà a vedere le casse,
ad esempio perché in alcune installazioni fisse
residenti le casse potrebbero essere state mascherate,
dietro telefono trasparenti,
cioè che sono trasparenti al suono ma non alla vista,
oppure se siamo in strutture architettoniche più complesse,
più lavorate,
potrebbero essere state integrate nell'architettura stessa del teatro,
rendendoci di fatto molto difficile individuarle a vista.
Ma torniamo al nostro palchetto all'aperto.
Sul podio c'è un microfono,
potrebbe essere quello chiamato normalmente gelato,
oppure il collo di cigno,
lo stelo,
quei microfoni molto sottili e snodati,
che si allunga dalla base del podio per cercare di
avvicinarsi il più possibile alla bocca del nostro oratore.
È quello che abbiamo visto prima,
cercare di posizionare il microfono il più
vicino possibile alla voce dell'oratore.
Tutti questi microfoni,
se seguiamo i cavi,
si concentrano in quelle che in gergo viene
chiamata "ciabatta audio" o "stage box",
cioè è un collettore di tutti questi microfoni
che hanno connessioni meccaniche standard,
li racchiude tutto in un unico grosso cavo e li porta al mixer.
Impotenziamo che il mixer sia a fianco al palco.
Questo trasporto è fatto in analogico,
potrebbe essere fatto in digitale,
ma su questa questione vorrei aprire una parentesi più avanti,
quindi per ora rimaniamo nell'analogico.
In questo caso,
rispetto all'esempio di prima,
il mixer ha il compito di unire più segnali microfonici,
quello del podio,
i vari segnali del tavolo,
oltre magari ad altri contributi,
video da computer,
musica da mettere nei tempi morti e svariate altre possibili sorgenti audio.
Da questo mixer escono due segnali,
tipicamente uno per il canale destro e uno per il canale sinistro,
che vanno non più direttamente alle casse,
facciamo caso,
ma a degli amplificatori separati,
cioè che sono apparecchiature,
normalmente standard rack,
che ricevono corrente,
ovviamente da una parte,
e il segnale audio del mixer.
A loro volta forniscono il segnale amplificato
che noi porteremo all'altoparlante,
quindi seguiamo questo cavo che effettivamente va all'altoparlante.
In questo caso parleremo di casse passive,
cioè che non hanno al loro interno l'amplificatore,
mentre definiamo le casse attive quando all'interno dello
stesso oggetto c'è sia il diffusore che l'amplificatore stesso.
Nelle casse attive ovviamente va portata corrente.
Non c'è una regola per cui è meglio un o meglio l'altro,
ci sono vantaggi e svantaggi a seconda di parecchi fattori.
Anche commercialmente,
a livelli medi e anche molto alti,
sono proposte entrambe le soluzioni,
quindi non è che uno è meglio dell'altro.
Saliamo ancora di livello,
passiamo a quello che potrebbe essere un grosso evento,
un grosso concerto.
Se siete stati a un grosso concerto o avete visto foto di installazioni,
di eventi di una certa dimensione,
molto probabilmente avrete notato quelli che si chiamano Line Array,
cioè lunghe file di casse che scendono appese ai lati del palco,
con una forma un po' inclinata,
infatti in gergo vengono anche chiamate "banane",
proprio perché scendono piegandosi.
Queste sono di fatto una serie di altoparlanti modulari,
tanti moduli collegati uno con l'altro,
piegate con strutture appositamente studiate e
appese molto al di sopra della testa delle persone,
proprio per fare in modo di distribuire meglio il suono.
La progettazione di questi impianti è un argomento molto complesso,
avviene attraverso simulazioni software,
parte molte volte proprio da un CAD 3D dell'ambiente da sonorizzare.
L'obiettivo è quello di bagnare tutta la platea,
l'area da coprire,
in maniera più uniformemente possibile.
Bagnare perché è come se stessi cercando di
bagnare la mia folla con un tubo dell'acqua,
non devo fare una cascata in un punto e lasciare un'altra zona a secco,
cioè devo cercare di distribuire la quantità
di suono nella maniera più uniforme possibile.
Questi sistemi infatti sono i più direttivi,
mi permettono di concentrare il suono dove voglio,
quindi oltre a evitare che chi sia sotto il palco venga
stordito dal suono e chi è in fondo non senta quasi niente,
riesce anche a concentrare il suono solo nella zona di interesse,
cercando di emetterne il meno possibile in ambiente per contenere il
disturbo che un forte volume provoca all'esterno della mia area di lavoro.
Anche in questo caso possiamo ritrovare i nostri elementi di partenza,
avremmo moltissimi emettitori,
moltissime casse altoparlanti e di conseguenza moltissimi finali,
gli amplificatori,
lo stadio finale della catena prima dello speaker.
Anche in questo caso gli amplificatori possono
essere integrati nel modulo del line array,
ci sono infatti line array attivi,
oppure oggetti separati e ci sono i line array passivi.
A seconda delle dimensioni si può tranquillamente parlare di decine di finali,
magari molti dedicati solo alla parte più acuta,
altri solo alla parte dei subwoofer,
la bassa frequenza,
tutti questi vengono gestiti separatamente.
Molto bene,
ma in questo esempio in grande siamo partiti però al contrario,
cioè guardando prima il sistema di amplificazione.
Ristalliamo allora la catena e arriviamo allo stadio prima,
cioè quello del mixer.
Il mixer,
e questo è valido anche per piccoli eventi,
è la postazione in cui il tecnico opera effettivamente durante l'evento.
Normalmente,
e se tutto va bene,
poi ovviamente le eccezioni esistono,
tutto il resto dell'impianto,
la scelta dei microfoni,
la loro posizione,
tutto il sistema di amplificazione,
la taratura di questo sistema,
ecco tutto questo viene allestito e tarato prima.
Durante l'evento la stragrande maggioranza del lavoro viene fatta proprio al
mixer ed è lì che si concentra la quasi totalità dell'operatività del tecnico.
Questo mixer,
anche chiamato banco audio,
gestisce molti microfoni,
ad esempio tutti quelli che arrivano dal palco
se immaginiamo che ci sia un gruppo che suona.
Poi magari c'è anche una presentazione,
dei presentatori parlano,
poi arrivano anche uno o due comici,
c'è un intervento in videoconferenza,
ci sono delle domande dal pubblico della sala,
quindi ci sono dei radiomicrofoni che girano,
dei contributi video.
Ecco,
adesso non andremo ad analizzare tutte le
varie casistiche di microfoni e di sorgenti,
ma sappiate che si raggiungono tranquillamente
in un evento dal vivo svariate decine di canali.
Infatti i mixer vengono scelti,
oltre che per le loro capacità di processo per la gestione dei segnali,
anche proprio per il numero di canali che riescono a trattare.
Possiamo andare da mixer piccoli che trattano pochi canali,
qualche decina di canali,
e perché no,
anche più di 100 canali nel caso delle situazioni più complesse.
Ovviamente per gestire un numero così alto di canali ci sono tutta
una serie di tecniche e strategie di raggruppamento e di utilizzo.
Senza però entrare nel dettaglio sui molteplici ingressi che un mixer ha,
secondo me è forse più interessante,
anche perché è un po' meno intuitivo,
raccontare invece le uscite che sono necessarie.
Allora,
finora abbiamo pensato solo all'uscita verso il pubblico,
dividendola magari in due canali,
sinistro e destro.
Ma in verità adesso andremo a vedere come di uscite da
gestire ce ne sono molte e sono molto diverse fra di loro.
E sono tutte gestite dal mixer,
o meglio dai mixer,
che potremo trovare in una situazione di evento.
Iniziamo con qualche esempio,
i musicisti sul palco.
Ogni musicista,
o quasi ogni gruppo di musicisti,
ha un ascolto dedicato,
dove sente un suono diverso da quello emesso dall'impianto.
Ma è proprio un mix creato per lui.
Se pensate ai monitor audio,
gli altoparlanti,
le casse che sono appoggiate sul bordo del palco e sono rivolte verso l'interno,
verso i musicisti,
oppure sempre più frequentemente si vedono gli in-ear monitor,
gli auricolari che tappano l'orecchio,
ecco,
a questi dispositivi arriva potenzialmente un segnale
molto diverso da quello che voi sentite come spettatori.
Perché i musicisti hanno bisogno di un ascolto dedicato?
Beh,
se ci pensate,
ogni musicista avrà la necessità di sentire il proprio strumento
magari leggermente più alto rispetto alla media degli altri,
perché in questo modo può tarare la sua esecuzione in maniera più precisa.
Anche qua,
normalmente,
le esecuzioni,
come avrete capito,
si sprecano in questo mondo.
Ad esempio,
un corista che nel mix finale risulterà in
sottofondo rispetto alla voce del cantante solista,
lui però avrà bisogno di sentire se è un volume più alto o avrà magari bisogno
di sentire alcuni strumenti di riferimento per prendere intonazione e tempo.
Ecco quindi che sto creando svariati mix a
seconda dei musicisti o dei gruppi di musicisti.
Chi esegue questi mix,
praticamente,
chi li fa,
anche qua dipende molto dalle dimensioni del nostro spettacolo.
Possiamo andare ad esempio in situazioni piccole,
in cui c'è un unico mixer di sala,
e addirittura i musicisti comunicano col fonico a gesti
o con le frasi durante il soundcheck "alzami questo",
"abbassami quest'altro".
Ma sempre più frequentemente,
soprattutto con l'avvento dei mixer digitali,
è ormai consuetudine vedere un tecnico di palco con un tablet.
Il tablet è collegato al mixer principale.
Quando vedete questo tecnico che si aggira fra i musicisti col tablet in mano,
quello che sta facendo,
molto probabilmente,
è quello di creare e controllare questi mix,
cioè gli ascolti ai musicisti.
In altre piccole situazioni,
addirittura,
magari quelli di gruppi o band che si autogestiscono,
ogni musicista,
tramite lo smartphone,
il telefono,
ha un'applicazione che gli permette di controllare direttamente la sua spia.
Quindi si crea lui il proprio mix e se lo aggiusta e se
lo tara durante il concerto e secondo le sue necessità.
In situazioni invece più grandi,
dove la gestione delle spie è complessa,
viene installato proprio un mixer dedicato,
un mixer di palco.
Fisicamente si trova normalmente a lato del palco,
nascosto dalle quinte,
e ha proprio lo scopo di gestire gli ascolti dei musicisti.
E c'è in questo caso un fonico di palco dedicato a questo.
E quindi già a questo punto abbiamo visto
svariate uscite diverse da quella principale,
tutte che riguardano però il palco e quello che succede nel palco.
Ma in verità non abbiamo finito qua.
Ad esempio,
sto facendo un evento dal vivo,
quindi ho il mio pubblico,
la mia uscita principale,
ma sto anche fornendo l'audio per lo streaming,
o per una videoconferenza,
o per una registrazione.
In verità,
tutte queste uscite sarebbe bene che non fossero esattamente la stessa cosa.
Pensate ad esempio alla differenza di ascolto
che può avere lo spettatore presente in sala,
rispetto a quello presente in streaming,
cioè che sta guardando l'evento dallo streaming.
Lo spettatore in sala,
durante un brano e l'altro,
rimaniamo sull'esempio del concerto,
sente tutta la sala,
tutti gli applausi,
la gente che batte le mani,
che fischia,
gli urli,
tutto il rumore.
Tutto questo suono non viene ripreso e amplificato nella sala,
creerebbe solo confusione.
Ma chi sta seguendo l'evento in streaming non è immerso in quell'ambiente,
non può sentire questo suono.
Ecco quindi che si potrebbe dedicare una ripresa sonora del pubblico,
o dell'ambiente della sala in cui ci troviamo,
e miscelarlo nell'uscita che viene mandata allo streaming,
rendendo quindi molto più coinvolgente la visione dello spettacolo.
Possiamo fare velocemente altri tipi di esempio.
Pensiamo a una batteria che suona dal vivo,
magari a un volume sufficiente per il mio piccolo pubblico,
e quindi non viene amplificata o viene molto poco amplificata in sala.
Mentre in streaming lo strumento dovrebbe essere molto
più presente rispetto al segnale che mando alle casse,
proprio perché lo spettatore in streaming
non sente la parte acustica della batteria.
E per finire,
anche i livelli audio variano molto.
Mentre in un evento dal vivo posso permettermi dinamiche molto
forti e con video emozionali dove carico molto il suono,
se gestisco lo streaming,
e quindi potenzialmente la gente lo guarda
su un telefono o sulle casse del computer,
non posso permettermi questi dislivelli di dinamica così pronunciati.
Ecco quindi che abbiamo fatto alcuni esempi di possibili
uscite aggentive e ce ne possono essere molte altre.
Ma quindi chi gestisce tutta questa complessità?
Come abbiamo visto anche un po' negli esempi,
possiamo andare dalla singola persona,
che con un singolo dispositivo,
con un singolo mixer,
deve gestire tutto,
fino a squadre di svariati tecnici,
con specializzazioni differenti,
compiti differenti,
apparecchiature differenti,
che collaborano e si devono coordinare fra di loro.
Ed ecco quindi che abbiamo concluso questa carrellata,
questa panoramica,
di quello che potremmo trovare in un evento dal vivo.
Abbiamo individuato i nostri macroelementi.
Ed eccoci arrivati in quest'ultima parte,
dove parleremo un po' più approfonditamente del mixer,
del banco audio,
dove opera effettivamente il fonico.
Che cosa fa,
perché lo fa.
Però inizierei quest'ultima parte aprendo una grande,
immensa parentesi,
ovvero la distinzione fra il mondo analogico e il mondo digitale.
Ora,
in questo podcast non entrerò nel dettaglio
della differenza fra analogico e digitale,
molti di voi probabilmente la conosceranno già,
molti di voi la conosceranno molto meglio di me.
Diciamo però,
in maniera estremamente brutale,
che quando parliamo di analogico,
di segnale analogico,
parliamo di segnale elettrici,
quindi siamo più nel mondo,
passatemi questa cosa,
fra virgolette dell'elettronica.
Un segnale appunto che mima,
che si muove in analogia con la mia grandezza fisica.
Mentre nel mondo digitale,
è sempre un segnale elettrico,
ma noi lo trattiamo come una serie di numeri,
cioè descriviamo la grandezza che ci interessa con dei numeri.
Questo sposta un po' l'attenzione,
cioè sposta il campo di lavoro da quello che può essere il mondo
elettronico a quello che può essere un mondo più informatica.
Facciamola così,
lasciamola così,
molto molto semplice.
Ma quindi perché si fa questa cosa?
Beh,
porta innumerevoli vantaggi.
Lasciamo perdere questioni assolute,
nel senso è meglio un mondo oppure è meglio un altro,
non sarà certo questo il luogo dove risolviamo questa infinita battaglia.
Ma diciamo che nel nostro caso porta moltissimi vantaggi,
porta anche qualche svantaggio.
Ed è per questo che nella realtà,
nella pratica,
ci troveremo sempre più spesso ad avere a che fare con mixer di tipo digitale.
Quindi,
chiarita questa cosa,
prima di vedere gli effettivi vantaggi che abbiamo da un mixer digitale,
facciamo quello che abbiamo fatto fino ad ora,
cioè inseriamo questo elemento nella nostra catena audio,
cioè dove avviene una conversione fra analogico-digitale e poi viceversa,
da digitale-analogico.
Perché una conversione così,
cioè un microfono riprenderà sempre un segnale analogico,
perché è una membrana che si muove,
riceve l'onda sonora.
Un altoparlante,
alla fine della catena,
riceverà anche lui sempre un segnale analogico,
perché dovrà vibrare in maniera analogo al segnale che vogliamo riprodurre.
Quindi nel mezzo ci sarà una conversione verso e da il digitale.
Anche un microfono USB,
che possiamo considerare un microfono puramente digitale,
come al solito non è altro che un oggetto che racchiude più elementi,
ovvero un microfono con la sua parte analogica,
probabilmente un qualche tipo di preamplificatore,
dopo un convertitore analogico-digitale e un'interfaccia
USB per permettermi di interfacciarsi al computer.
Questi tipi di dispositivo ci sono,
ce ne sono molti,
ma nel mondo live è un po' difficile trovarli,
proprio perché la connessione USB non ha una connessione adatta
a coprire le grandi distanze e nel mondo degli spettacoli
al vivo le grandi distanze vanno tenute in considerazione.
Rimaniamo quindi in una situazione più classica
e diciamo che stiamo usando un mixer digitale.
Un mixer digitale ha tipicamente alcune connessioni analogiche al suo interno,
ciò mi permette di acquisire un certo numero di segnali,
ma non sono tutti i segnali che il mixer può gestire.
Facciamo un esempio,
io ho un mixer che può gestire 32 canali in ingresso,
ma solo 8 o solo 16 di questi canali me li ritrovo
effettivamente come connessioni analogiche,
cioè che hanno il preamplificatore e i convertitori analogico digitale.
In questo caso potrei trasportare le sorgenti che mi arrivano ad
esempio dal palco tramite delle fruste audio o una stage box analogica,
che sono cioè un raggruppamento di tanti segnali audio fatto tramite
un unico cavo al cui interno in verità ci sono tanti conduttori,
che quindi mi permettono di trasportare agevolmente
diversi canali audio in analogico da un punto a un altro.
Però come dicevamo potenzialmente il mixer audio può gestire più di questi
canali e quelli che non riesce a gestire con le sue connessioni analogiche
interne tipicamente possiamo acquisirli tramite dei convertitori analogico
digitali e preamplificatori ovviamente esterni e in
questo caso ci sono proprio le stage box digitali.
Questi dispositivi cioè hanno al loro interno tutto quello
che occorre per fare la conversione analogico digitale e
mandare il segnale digitale direttamente al nostro mixer.
Il percorso quindi della stage box al mixer viene fatto in digitale,
il mixer lo accetta come uno degli altri canali
ed elabora il segnale come abbiamo visto prima.
Questa cosa può succedere anche al contrario ovvero anche per le uscite quindi
io posso avere delle uscite analogiche direttamente sul mixer oppure il
mixer può fornirmi tramite delle stage di uscita il
segnale audio che dopo manderò agli amplificatori.
In alcuni casi addirittura gli amplificatori possono accettare
un segnale digitale e quindi se parlano la stessa lingua,
lo stesso standard,
posso andare dal mixer all'amplificatore direttamente in
digitale senza avere la conversione analogica nel mezzo.
Sarà poi l'amplificatore a ricreare il
segnale analogico da inviare agli speaker.
E' interessante secondo me capire quali sono le
due grosse famiglie di questo mondo digitale.
Sto parlando di un mondo sicuramente in evoluzione,
ci sono tantissimi standard.
Ma potrebbe essere interessante soprattutto in questo
podcast distinguere appunto queste due famiglie,
quella un po' più digitale classica e quella
invece TCP/IP cioè proprio rete dati.
Nel primo caso cioè quello del segnale digitale più classico,
perdonatemi questo termine non so come altro definirlo,
la connessione tra il mio mixer e la mia stage ad esempio può avvenire
tramite diversi tipi di cablaggio possono essere cavi ottici,
cavi quassiali,
anche cavi di rete,
ma non si parla in questo caso di rete dati.
E' un segnale definito con degli standard,
ci sono molti standard diversi che ne determinano il clock,
la frequenza,
le tensioni,
le correnti in gioco e possiamo immaginarlo
come una gigantesca trasmissione seriale.
Ovviamente per accoppiare vari dispositivi è assolutamente
richiesto che tali dispositivi utilizzino lo stesso standard.
In alcuni casi ci sono addirittura delle schede
di espansione dedicate ad ogni standard,
quindi posso avere nel mio mixer uno slot di espansione
e compro una scheda che mi permette di parlare MADI,
uno standard digitale,
oppure AES50,
oppure ADA.
Insomma ci sono vari tipi di standard che vengono usati per vari scopi.
Per quanto riguarda invece il tipo di trasmissione IP,
ovvero proprio una trasmissione dati,
ultimamente negli ultimi anni si stanno affacciando diversi standard.
Ci sono consorsi che si stanno sviluppando,
tanti standard diversi per garantire
l'interoperabilità di tutte le apparecchiature.
Ci sono alcuni che potremmo definire quasi degli standard di fatto,
ovvero sono i più utilizzati e i più comuni da trovare in tutti i dispositivi,
ma la battaglia è ancora aperta.
Non c'è un unico vincitore definitivo,
si stanno ancora confrontando e probabilmente si svilupperanno
altri tipi di connessioni in futuro o si creeranno
delle integrazioni fra questi tipi di connessioni.
Il vantaggio principale di questo tipo di trasmissione
è quello di poterlo gestire esattamente come una rete,
quindi posso farlo passare negli switch,
posso raggrupparli,
posso gestirli,
creo una specie di matrice virtuale all'interno della
mia rete dove posso avere più moduli d'ingresso,
più moduli di uscita.
Creo un'infrastruttura molto molto flessibile,
facilmente espandibile e completamente gestita da un punto di vista proprio IT.
Si entra effettivamente nel mondo,
nel campo dell'IT e dei sistemi.
Questa cosa si porta anche alcuni svantaggi,
ad esempio le problematiche della rete,
con la particolare attenzione perché nell'audio
dobbiamo stare attentissimi alle latenze.
Poche decine di millisecondi di ritardo nel ricreare il segnale
possono compromettere la riuscita di tutta la mia catena audio.
Quindi ci sono degli switch che lavorano con determinati tipi di protocolli,
bisogna costruire le reti in un certo modo,
ci sono anche qua delle certificazioni per l'audio over IP,
bisogna avere quindi delle competenze specifiche per
poter creare e gestire questa infrastruttura di rete.
Se per una configurazione base,
cioè dove colleghiamo un mixer con una stage box,
tiriamo un cavo punto a punto,
tutto tendenzialmente funziona senza grossi problemi,
nel momento in cui creiamo invece molti nodi,
interfacciamo molteplici dispositivi,
ecco lì non ci si può più improvvisare.
E queste sono competenze che iniziano ad allontanarsi dal
mondo dell'audio puro e si avvicinano al mondo dei sistemi,
dell'IT.
A tutta questa complessità si aggiunge anche poi il mondo del video,
che anch'esso sta affrontando un'evoluzione che lo
porta sempre di più verso il mondo delle rete dati.
Infatti tutto questo mondo lo si trova spesso riassunto con la voce IP over IP,
cioè audio e video su trasmissioni IP.
Ok,
detto tutto questo,
che vantaggi ci dà affrontare tutta questa complessità del mondo digitale?
Come prima cosa però assolutamente non scontata è che in una trasmissione
digitale possiamo garantire un trasporto del segnale molto pulito,
privo di interferenze,
o meglio non è privo di interferenze,
ma fintando che il segnale digitale è perfettamente intellegibile non
avrò differenza tra il mio punto di appartenza e il mio punto di arrivo.
Un segnale analogico invece si deteriora
nel percorso e va trattato con molta cura.
Un altro grosso vantaggio è quello della dimensione e del peso,
che sembra forse sciocco ma non lo è assolutamente.
Nel mondo analogico ho bisogno di un certo
spazio fisico dove farsare la circuiteria.
Ogni canale dispone di una certa circuiteria,
quindi all'aumentare del numero di canali devo
necessariamente aumentare lo spazio a disposizione.
Un mixer a 8 canali sarà fisicamente più piccolo
e peserà molto meno di un mixer a 32-48 canali.
Sarà necessariamente più grande,
con un maggior peso e un maggior costo anche di trasporto e di gestione.
E non si parla solo del numero di canali,
perché un mixer digitale mi permette tutta una serie di elaborazioni del segnale
che per farle in analogico avrei bisogno di quello che si dice un outboard,
cioè un processore esterno analogico specifico per quel tipo di processo.
È un oggetto che ha un suo peso,
un suo ingombro,
un certo costo e occupa un certo spazio nella mia regia.
Ad esempio se voglio avere un compressore sulla voce,
magari più avanti accenniamo ad alcuni di questi processi,
nel mondo analogico avrò bisogno effettivamente
di un compressore che può trattarmi pochi canali.
Alcuni processi sono già integrati nei mixer analogici,
ma sono proprio quelli basilari.
In tanti altri casi si usavano,
e si usano tuttora per chi sceglie la strada analogico,
outboard esterni,
quindi rack interi a fianco al mixer.
E chiaramente se lo devo fare per pochi canali,
uno o due canali è un discorso,
ma se voglio immaginare di avere un compressore su ognuno dei miei,
che ne so,
32 canali,
devo avere 32 compressori.
La faccenda inizia a diventare un po' complicata da gestire.
Nel mondo digitale invece ho i compressori.
In molti casi addirittura posso avere delle simulazioni,
fatte più o meno bene,
dei processori analogici,
perché magari mi piacciono particolarmente quel tipo di processo analogico,
e col passare degli anni ultimamente è sempre più facile riuscire ad
avere un'emulazione digitale dell'effetto che avevo in analogico.
Molto bene,
e quindi che cosa fa un mixer,
questo oggetto su cui alla fine abbiamo visto che si
concentra quasi tutta l'operatività del nostro tecnico?
È ovviamente difficile raccontare tutto,
e forse anche poco interessante,
ma facciamo delle macro-categorie di processo.
Alcuni riguardano la dinamica,
ovvero la differenza fra i suoni più forti e i suoni più bassi.
Quindi possiamo ridurre questa dinamica,
possiamo ampiare questa dinamica,
tutto con lo scopo di focalizzare l'attenzione
sulla parte di suono che ci interessa.
Quindi magari rafforzando le parti basse della voce,
oppure al contrario riducendo il brusio che invece non vogliamo amplificare,
solo per fare un esempio.
Ci sono poi interventi che riguardano l'equalizzazione,
quindi senza entrare nello specifico,
diciamo i suoni più scuri,
i suoni più acuti,
più brillanti,
e allora anche in questo caso andiamo a rafforzarne alcuni,
andiamo a eliminarne altri,
a seconda di quello che ci interessa.
Ci sono poi degli interventi specifici,
molto tecnici,
pensiamo ad esempio all'effetto Larsen,
cioè il fischio che quasi sicuramente avete sentito in un evento dal vivo.
Cioè quel fastidioso effetto che si verifica quando il microfono capta,
se vogliamo in maniera troppo forte,
il suono che esso stesso amplifica.
Provo a spiegarlo in due parole molto semplicemente,
io parlo a un microfono,
la mia voce viene amplificata e la voce
amplificata però rientra anche nel microfono,
che a sua volta verrà amplificata,
che a sua volta rientrerà nel microfono e ci sarà
un livello in cui questo loop si autoalimenta,
generando proprio il fischio,
perché per ragioni tecniche avviene prima su alcune frequenze specifiche.
Ecco quindi che con un intervento particolare sull'equalizzazione
vado a cercare di togliere energia in queste frequenze problematiche,
per cercare di ridurre l'effetto Larsen,
di ridurre la probabilità che questo fischio si inneschi.
Come ad esempio posso equalizzare anche le uscite,
ovvero la mia diffusione in sala,
perché l'ambiente,
ogni sala reagisce in maniera diversa e quindi avrò bisogno
di aumentare o di ridurre energia in particolare zone dello
spettro audio per far sentire al meglio il mio suono.
Abbiamo poi tutta una serie di effetti se
vogliamo più creativi come i riverberi,
i delay,
i chorus,
ovvero tutta una serie di cose che rendono più piacevole il mio suono
o addirittura proprio che le uso in maniera creativa per creare,
per generare un certo tipo di effetto.
Questo avviene molto di più ovviamente nel
musicale rispetto che nella conferenza,
però sono tutti strumenti che il fonico ha a disposizione
e deve saper usare e calibrare all'esigenza.
E quindi per finire operativamente il nostro
tecnico che cosa fa durante l'evento?
Beh lui avrà fatto quasi sicuramente anche le prove
prima o se non lo ha fatto avrà una scaletta,
dovrà interagire con tutte le persone che sono andate sul palco
e quindi dovrà seguire di fatto quello che succede nell'evento,
accendere e spegnere i microfoni,
adattarli a seconda delle esigenze,
modellare il suono secondo le varie esigenze e
seguire in pratica quello che succede sul palco.
E un po' passatemi il paragone come se fosse il cuoco
o il cameriere che vi serve il piatto in tavola,
cioè che prende gli ingredienti grezzi,
ovvero il prodotto dell'artista sul palco,
li unisce,
li plasma,
li confeziona,
li miscela per voi e ve li serve al vostro tavolo.
Oltre a tutta la dimensione tecnica che abbiamo visto finora
non sottovalutiamo tutta una dimensione e un aspetto umano,
soprattutto con quei tecnici che hanno che fare sempre con persone diverse,
problematiche diverse e esigenze diverse.
Sapersi interfacciare con le persone in situazioni che possono essere molto
stressanti come quelle degli eventi dal vivo perché non lasciano molto
tempo per prendere delle decisioni o per risolvere dei problemi,
ecco la componente umana nell'affrontare,
nel cercare di risolvere queste problematiche tutte
insieme fa molto secondo me e non è da sottovalutare.
E proprio per finire in coda non vogliamo spendere le ultime parole per parlare
delle evoluzioni future citando addirittura l'intelligenza artificiale.
Ecco con queste ultime due parole probabilmente ho già perso
la quasi totalità di voi perché effettivamente è un problema
sentire a parlare molto spesso a sproposito di questo argomento,
però volevo lanciarmi in quella che può essere una proiezione futura data
dalla mia esperienza e queste sono considerazioni assolutamente personali,
in questo caso non c'è assolutamente niente di tecnico
su quello che potremo aspettarci nei prossimi anni.
Sicuramente l'evoluzione del digitale con la sua capacità di calcolo la farà
da padrona e vedremo arrivare o affinare nuovi processi in questa catena.
Non credo se arriverà entro breve a una
sostituzione del tecnico alla sua professionalità,
credo piuttosto che compariranno sempre di più a costi sempre più
accessibili strumenti a supporto del suo lavoro magari molto automatici
ma che comunque si vanno a integrare nel suo flusso di lavoro.
Mi vengono in mente ad esempio gli ultimi algoritmi di pulizia del suono che
si possono utilizzare in post produzione e di cui si inizia a vedere qualcosa
anche nelle situazioni live in cui ovviamente il tempo di elaborazione
deve essere estremamente ridotto e se non virtualmente assente.
Come pure vedo sempre più probabile l'ingresso di automatismi di automixing
cioè di una gestione semiautomatica dei livelli magari in una situazione
molto più controllata come può essere quella di una conferenza.
Oppure come ultimo esempio la taratura di un impianto potrebbe trarre molto
vantaggio poterla fare anche a chi non ha competenze specifiche sulla
taratura degli impianti ma riesce comunque con un
sistema automatico a ottenere un buon risultato.
Magari lui si concentra o può concentrarsi su altri aspetti del lavoro e con
questo direi che ho finito spero di avervi almeno in parte incuriosito e perché
no la prossima volta che assisterete a un concerto buttate un occhio al dietro
le quinte a tutta la parte tecnica che si cela
nascosta normalmente agli occhi del pubblico.
Grazie a tutti voi che siete sopravvissuti l'ascolto soprattutto grazie mille
a Valerio che mi ha dato la possibilità di raccontarvi queste piccole cose e
continuate a seguire il podcast pensieri
in codice grazie a tutti di nuovo e ciao
Grazie mille a te,
Alex,
per averci fatto capire che,
dietro alla gestione del suono di un evento,
c'è un intero mondo di tecnologia,
di software e di persone al lavoro.
E complimenti anche per la chiarezza e l'impegno.
So che non è banale produrre 40 minuti di discorso continuo e lineare.
Pensieri in codice,
a prima vista,
sembra in tutto e per tutto un podcast dedicato all'informatica.
Scavando un po' più a fondo,
però,
dovrebbe apparire chiaro che in realtà si tratta di uno spazio nel
quale mi piace ragionare insieme a te su come funzionano le cose,
e a volte anche le persone.
Il fatto che poi il progetto abbia un taglio informatico,
beh,
dipende dal fatto che io sono un informatico.
E quindi il mio modo di pensare si riflette su ogni aspetto della mia vita,
compreso questo progetto.
Quando dunque Alex si è proposto per un episodio della serie Community Edition,
nonostante i suoi dubbi sul fatto che l'argomento
non fosse prettamente legato al software,
io ho subito pensato che sarebbe stato invece
un contenuto interessantissimo da condividere.
E penso di non essermi sbagliato.
Tu che ne dici?
Secondo me oggi abbiamo imparato tutti qualcosa di nuovo,
me compreso,
ed è questo il senso di questa serie.
Alex,
che,
ripeto,
nella vita è responsabile tecnico audiovisivo,
mi ha detto anche che ha intenzione di aprire un proprio progetto divulgativo.
Io dico che ci sono tutte le carte in regola,
quindi mi sento di incoraggiarlo assolutamente.
Non so quando ciò diverrà realtà,
ma se vuoi saperne di più su audio e argomenti tecnici del genere,
ti consiglio di unirti al gruppo Telegram di Pensieri in Codice,
dove,
sono sicuro,
Alex ci terrà aggiornati sulle novità del suo progetto.
Nel frattempo veniamo al consueto invito.
Come hai sentito,
questa nuova rubrica si chiama Pensieri in Codice Community Edition,
perché è uno spazio pensato apposta per te
che fai parte della community del podcast.
Se hai un'idea che ti affascina,
un'esperienza interessante da raccontare o semplicemente
un argomento legato al mondo dell'informatica che ti
appassiona e che ritieni adatto per questi microfoni,
perché non lo condividi?
È un modo fantastico per metterti alla
prova e supportare attivamente il progetto,
impiegando il tuo talento,
e restituire un po' del valore che spero
tu riceva ascoltando Pensieri in Codice.
Te lo assicuro,
non è complicato,
e non serve essere un esperto o avere un'attrezzatura professionale.
Come dico sempre,
è quasi come registrare un vocale,
e in ogni caso ci sarò io a guidarti passo passo.
Quindi,
se hai una proposta,
puoi contattarmi su Telegram o scrivermi
all'indirizzo email valerio@pensierincodice.it,
mi raccomando,
con due i,
e ne parliamo insieme.
Trovi tutti i link sul sito pensierincodice.it.
Io non vedo l'ora di sentire le tue idee.
Prima di salutarci,
inoltre,
ti rinnovo il mio invito a riflettere sulla filosofia
value for value su cui si fonda questo progetto.
Ancora una volta,
Pensieri in Codice è un podcast totalmente indipendente,
libero da pubblicità e da tracciamenti,
che porto avanti esclusivamente nel mio tempo libero con le mie
risorse personali e con un po' di aiuto da parte della community.
Questo vuol dire che per sopravvivere e continuare a crescere,
ha bisogno anche del tuo supporto.
L'idea è semplice.
Se ascolti tanti episodi,
se magari hai imparato qualcosa di nuovo,
o hai trovato uno spunto interessante,
ti chiedo di fermarti un secondo e riflettere.
Quanto vale per te questo progetto?
Se la risposta è che un valore ce l'ha,
allora ti chiedo di valutare,
senza nessun obbligo,
se restituirne una piccola parte.
Puoi farlo nei tre modi che la filosofia value for value ci insegna,
time,
talent o treasure.
Time.
Puoi dedicare un po' del tuo tempo per far crescere Pensieri in Codice.
Il passaparola è fondamentale,
quindi condiviti questo o un altro episodio,
con un amico,
un collega o sui tuoi social.
Portare nuovi ascoltatori è il primo modo per sostenere tutta la baracca.
Talent.
Se hai competenze che pensi possano essere utili,
mettile a disposizione.
Come dico spesso,
mi farebbe comodo una mano per aprire e gestire i canali social.
Ma magari tu sai scrivere,
sai fare ricerche o vuoi proporti per un episodio della Community Edition?
Beh,
scrivimi e parliamone.
Infine,
treasure.
Puoi scegliere di dare un supporto economico,
anche piccolo.
È quello che fanno donatori come Edoardo e Carlo,
che ringrazio sempre per il loro sostegno mensile.
Se vuoi unirti a loro,
trovi tutti i modi per farlo,
come ad esempio Satispay o Revolut,
nella sezione "Sostieni" del sito pensieriincodice.it.
Sempre con due "i",
mi raccomando.
Qualsiasi modo sceglierai,
il tuo contributo sarà prezioso e apprezzato.
A questo punto direi che ci siamo detti proprio tutto e ci
possiamo salutare dandoci appuntamento al prossimo episodio
e ricordando sempre che un informatico risolve problemi,
a volte,
anche usando il computer.